are monitoring the air quality for the  players and as the air quality good that  is exactly what a niche Geary needs  right now  yeah he needs to use every single  Advantage he can get and wow well hint  for the penny in for the pound and uh  Anish just sacrificing a bishop oh the  bar jumps up  uh it does look like decent air quality  uh there in San Francisco I'm not sure  that's going to help I need to get ready  though because he has just given up a  bishop we talked about White's Knight  needing to get into the game and it has  finally sprung to life and uh okay it  has come at the cost of the whole Bishop  though White's given up a bishop for a  pawn just to break Black's Pawn chain  that previously proud chain of Pawns has  been  shattered and there are some weaknesses  some targets but there's no  I mean I just don't see any downside to  Black trying to force the Queens off as  we indicated